[Music]
thank you thanks for having me here for
inviting me here so what I will try to
talk about is actually not about
theories of the brain but maybe in some
sense how do you actually learn series
right what does it mean to have a good
theory and how do you infer a theory but
the example that I will go to that I
will talk about actually do not relate
to the actual neural computation which
is the topic of this workshop and in
fact I could have talked something I
could have talked about different
examples of brain computational series
of brain capitation I proposed a few
topic titles to the organizers my lab
generally studies things like
information processing in biological
systems we try to figure out the general
laws the computational principles of
that those are just a few examples so
for example we have discovered that in
the developing mammary ducts in mammals
there is really an information theoretic
relay channel for which we can calculate
the channel capacity and see that the
that the cells actually achieve the
bounds that are the information
theoretic bounds that exist in this
channel we can we study things like
information transduction in protein
signaling pathways like an F Kappa B
protein pathway where if you cut
yourself and things turned purple or
pink whatever it is that the color that
things turn that's because of this in
occupied B signaling system and we can
calculate the channel capacity in the
system and see what limits the
computation in the system we study
systems with multiple different
receptors and multiple different
molecules and then on the brain side
what we try to do is we study
reinforcement learning or equivalent of
reinforcement learning in real animals
like for example in this worm which
learns to associate temperature and food
and then makes a decision whether to go
to the port temperature the cold
temperature and it turns out that the
model that we can build to fit the data
the way that I show
and the models are a bit more
complicated than simple reinforcement
learning they include multiple time
scales and so on same story with birds
with study birds that learn to sing or
learn to adjust their song based on
perturbations and there we realize that
for example maybe there are computation
different computational ideas that the
birds actually do compared to what we're
normally things they do it turns out
that their singing is very widely
distributed with very very long tails in
the distribution of their songs in both
pitches and amplitudes and so on and so
if you put this into the model of the of
how the birds long if you don't assume
that the fluctuations are small Gaussian
distributed but actually do have long
tails then you can beget feeds to real
data you know how quickly the birds long
a new perturbation which are sort of as
good as this plots alright so we work on
other things in the and in the brain
computation so for example one of the
last pieces of work that we have done we
have shown that the information encoding
in muscles right and is a motor neurons
or in the neurons the directly synapse
to our muscles doesn't proceed by rate
at least in birds right doesn't proceed
by the rate of the number of spikes
emitted doesn't even proceed by timing
of individual spikes but the information
encoding is given by patterns of spikes
and the timing of spikes within a multi
spike patterns of three or four spikes
put together and so this is some of this
thing that I can talk about I am very
willing to talk about them later at the
end of this talk during the breaks if
somebody is interested but what I was
asked to talk about by organizing by
volgen is something else different
pieces of forged but that my group has
worked on and that work has been done
primarily by Brian Dennis with the
research faculty now to Arizona State
and the experimental data that I will
point or that I will show comes from a
lab of unrelieved chenkin will rule in
Yale and Toronto respectively so let's
start this topic with this actual meat
of the talk with this short story by
Borges it's a whole short story of
exactly that in science I'm sure that
many of you have seen this talk but this
short story ham bread
word story in that Empire is a craft of
cartography attained such perfection
that the map of a single province
covered the space of an entire city and
the map of the Empire itself an entire
province in the course of time this
extensive maps were found somehow
wanting and so the College of
cartographers evolved a map of the
Empire that was of the same scale as
Empire and inside it was at point four
point less attentive to the study of
cartography succeeding generations came
to charge him up of such magnitude
cumbersome and not without irreverence
they abandoned it to the rigors of Sun
and rain in the western desert tattered
fragments of the map a still to be found
shelter and occasional beasts to beggar
and in the whole nation neither like his
left of the discipline of geography okay
and I think that this short story by
Borges sort of gives us you know a
literary fable in some sense of what is
happening with our current progress of
building ever more detailed theories
ever more detailed models of various
different biological systems including
the brain right so this discussions this
sort of thought process for me started
maybe at the cns meeting in 2014 where
there was a very large panel discussion
and the meeting and the question that
was as there what it is what is going to
be the final series of the brain right
somebody asked that that question and
the general sort at that table during
the panel discussion was more or less
something like that the final theory of
of the brain the final serie of just
pretty much any biological system will
be a large multi scale computational
model and what we need to do is we need
to generate more and more data to fit
all of the details all of the parameters
of this model right and I see that there
is a lot of issues with this at least
but I was listening that at the time I
realized I don't think of series as a
large computational model right large
multi scale models with a million of
parameters first of all I don't
understand what is the meaning of a
final theory right is Newton's law
you know F equal MA and the gravitation
universal gravitation one over R squared
is it the final theory of everything of
course not right there are great there
are quantum mechanical Corrections there
are relativistic Corrections as we keep
you know hundreds of thousands of
physicists nowadays keep on working on
making even a better seer
right even the more accurate theory when
you combine relativity and gravity your
gravity and quantum mechanics together
and yet there is no success and at some
sense we still believe that Newton's
laws of gravity are a good theory right
they're not a final theory by any means
but they're a good theory I don't think
we ever actually need a final theory of
anything in either any biological system
or in any physical system there is no
final theory of this Cup that people
have been showing here all the time
right and as a specific series that you
will have for that cap will depend on
what you want to do with this cap if you
want to figure out how it breaks when
you drop it then that's a very different
theory than if you want to calculate how
quickly it's actually going to drop to
the floor
or how it's going to heat up as you put
it on the you know windowsill and and
and and the sun is shining on it right
there is not a single theory that covers
all of the questions that you can ask
about that cap and maybe we shouldn't be
doing the same thing when we're trying
to build a theory of the bulbs brain or
whatever system were trying to model
there's a very famous saying in from
lyrick I don't know if you know one of
the founding fathers of modern
statistical physics don't mold model
bulldozers with quartz and so the idea
there is that if you're trying to model
large-scale behavior but what I try to
maybe point out yesterday I'd say at the
final discussion they're trying to model
behavior of the brain it doesn't it's
not entirely obvious that neurons and
synapses as a right abstract abstraction
to model what the brain does and how the
computation actually is happening in
this brain right we wouldn't ever dare
to model the big macroscopic object by
simulating quarks and electrons and all
that stuff inside that object and yet
for some reason we think that we need to
be solving the brain one neuron at the
time and then putting them all together
and figuring out what the brain does
right so in some sense the idea here the
theories must lose details and must be
developed to explain a limited set of
phenomena right and that's what maybe
makes a good theory is that it explains
a limited set of phenomena correctly and
it throws away everything that wasn't
designed for and so of course otherwise
if you want to try to model everything
then the best material model of
is another or preferably the same cat
right we don't really want to build a
model of a cat on a scale of 1 to 1 just
like I don't think we want to build a
theory or model of a brain on the scale
of 1 to 1 and I'm deliberately for now
mixing ABS theories and models and maybe
we'll come back to this distinction
later if I actually finish sometime so
another thing that that volgen asked me
to talk a bit about is this question
what does it make what what makes a good
theory right and so I thought for a bit
about this a few years back and it turns
out that even in physics we really
believe that the reserve understand what
a good theory is when we see it it's not
a clear answer right what makes a good
theory so first of all yes everybody
again knows this phrase that was for
parameters I can fit an elephant in
verse five I can make it wiggle its
trunk right this was attributed to one
Newman so this has the idea that you
probably don't want to build our series
on the scale of one to one and then why
because such series can explain
everything right there in some sense not
falsifiable you can just wiggle
parameters by a bit and and your model
is going to do whatever it is that you
want this model to do right and so maybe
what makes a good theory is that the
theory is falsifiable but not yet
falsified but then how do we actually
account you know how do we be in
quantitative scientists how do we model
how do we explain what falsifiable and
unfalsifiable the theory of something so
we have been all witnesses here of
quantitative biology revolution business
in neuroscience or systems biology or
population biology and so maybe there is
also time now to start thinking about
quantitative philosophy of science right
so where we stop philosophizing but
actually calculate things and again as I
said even in physics where we know what
what theory good theory is the problem
is pretty bit right this is a story from
a few years back where an experiment
bicep2 has measured what people thought
was a signature of RAM or Dell sort of
certain features of of inflation and
then it turned and then the models of
inflation explains also those
observations and then a few months later
as a series propose that those exactly
same observations can be explained by
cosmic dust and then the inflationary
series were immediately adjusted to not
be explaining that to not require
existence of that feature and the
experiment right which started a whole
through part of process of
soul-searching in theoretical physics
you know what do we mean by having a
good theory of inflation or you know of
fundamental physics if this theory can
explain both an experiment and its
inverse right you just tweak a few
parameters and and both both things you
know essentially every experimental data
is is explainable by that theory is it
an a good theory and it's the only Syria
to have it might be that it's a true
seer it might be that it's really what's
happening in the world but it can
explain everything is it a good theory
right and there was a big conference of
philosophers and physicists which is
where this picture is taken from you
know a year later somewhere in Germany
where sort of this was the mood in the
room right people philosophers couldn't
tell us what is a good theory and what
is not a good theory right so so my
thought about this and this is sort of
set in obviously the agenda for the rest
of the talk is that maybe we should not
ask philosophers to tell us what a good
theory is but instead what we should
realize that most Akata means if you are
presented with a dichotomy a good theory
or a bad theory everyday economy is most
likely false right there is a grayscale
of something that goes from all the way
from a good theory to a very bad theory
and maybe we shouldn't be asking
philosophers to define for us what that
demarcation is but rather we understand
already is that in order to do science
anyway we have to use statistics
statistics is crucial for us right we
feed the data in order to know that the
data is fitted by the theory we have to
use statistics and maybe statistics
itself already tells us which series are
good and which series are bad because
statistics can't quantify at least for
example Bayesian statistics which I
usually practice it cannot really 25:4
us what is falsifiable and what is and
what is falsified right so if I go and
what skip this if I go and I just try to
calculate what is the probability that
this serie is given by data which is of
course by Bayes theorem proportional to
the probability of receiving data from
Siri and I do some kind of a Bayesian
calculation sort of Bayesian approach to
this and then the all of these integrals
are going to be given by a log
likelihood and some account factors
right and in some sense what this means
is that the first term tells us if the
Siri is falsified or not how well it's
it fits the data right and then the
second term tells us if it's falsifiable
or not how many other data sets can it
explain
and so if the same Siri can explain
multiple data sets then the then this
term is going to be pretty large and and
it's not a good theory it can explain
everything that you can attach to it
right that you can give it give it and
in some sense there is not going to be a
clear-cut distinction that this is a
good series as a bad series some series
can be can have a large likelihood than
others right and this could come from
the fact that they fit better but maybe
are less falsifiable and some series may
have a larger likelihood they fit a bit
worse but they're more falsifiable and
there's going to be a balance somewhere
there but I don't think that we should
be sort of defining in some sense that
you know a series that includes every
single new dissimulation inside the
brain etcetera etcetera is the only one
that is good or it's completely bad
because it is it has too many parameters
so this term is bad or if the theory is
great because it can actually fit
everything that you like because this
term is good right maybe this is an
obvious thing to to to many of you in
the room but to me it wasn't when I
started thinking about this because
immediately the next point that you can
make starting from here is when you
start working with series and trying to
develop a theory of a process then you
are rejecting the statement you know the
idea that the good theory is the theory
which is a correct one right and a true
one right the importance of a theory is
to be able to make predictions is to be
able to generalize is to be able to
explain the data that you haven't seen
and we really don't care to to a large
extent whether this is whether the
theory is correct or not as long as it
works it's good enough right that's what
those arguments will probably
sadistically arguments will tell us and
this is a case that maybe what we should
be doing is not to start modeling
systems sort of with by respecting
biological accuracy right because we
already have decided that this is not
the most important or at least I've
decided this is not the most important
thing but rather try to model systems by
just developing phenomenological models
which are good enough to predict what
the system is going to be doing right so
you observe a few experiments you built
a model and if your model is able to
predict what's going to come next and
it's a good it's a good model of the
system if it can't then it's a bad model
of a system and and if we're doing this
and it's necessary that this models will
be phenomenological right they will not
account for every microscope you know
they will not be biologically accurate
or not necessarily biological accurate
we don't care about this is not a
criteria for finding a model and the
series would of course not answer every
question but they will only answer the
question for which they were designed
right so if you put if you ask them to
explain a certain set of experimental
observations they will do it well and
make predictions on similar data but
it's okay it doesn't make a theory wrong
if the theory is not able to predict
totally different class of experiments
right Newton's laws gravitation of
gravitation are still a good theory even
though they are not able to tell me
whether this cap is going to break when
it hits a floor or not right so then the
next question that one can ask if we
have forgotten this idea of biological
or physical accuracy can we by looking
at the data just learn what an effective
model of this data is and maybe we can
try to use modern computing modern AI
techniques to actually try to do
something along this lines and that's
what I'm going to spend the next 15
minutes or and show you some toy
examples and then show you maybe one or
two biological examples including
behavior of C elegans example so what is
it we're really trying to do for
simplicity and for now we can extend
this a bit but for simplicity what we
started with is we assume that the
dynamics of network right so so the
let's remove cellular here right the
dynamics of the system not the cellular
network necessarily but a system is
temporarily local right
whatever system I'm working at visit the
warm visit activity of the brain right
and it's given therefore by ordinary
differential equations okay and any
temporary local dynamics we should be
able to write down in terms of some set
of ordinary differential equations we're
not going to feed the curves not the
dynamics itself not the trajectories of
the system what we're going to do is
we're going to try to feed the dynamics
meaning that if I'm going to neglect the
cast ECT and I'm going to neglect for
now spatial structure I just have a few
time series that I'm trying to
understand right this becomes a problem
of time series prediction and at the
time serious maybe x1 x2 and what I'm
trying to do I'm trying to guess a
system that looks like this based on a
few observations of this time series
right so I have a sequence x1 of time x2
of time and I'm asked to build a model
that looks like this and why is this
complicated we know for many reasons
first of all we need to automatically
feed this functions of eyes and how do i
enumerate all possible dynamical systems
right how do I figure out how do i
numerate all possible right-hand sides
in this equation and then the second
problem how do I search through this
list even if I am able to to enumerate
this whole list right and then on top of
it if I have a very very large list from
where I'm from which I'm searching how
do I not overfeed but that's a bit more
technical so of course we're not the
first ones to ask this type of questions
people have been trying to do this ever
since the 80s when sort of all of the
dynamical system nonlinear dynamics have
evolved as a discipline most of the
approach is focused on what I would call
coarse graining where you start with a
microscopically accurate system and then
you start removing details and seeing
what is the gist of that calculation
what is the gist of that dynamics and I
maintains that this is good thing to do
in a physical system but not really a
good thing to do in a biological system
work and as a complex system the reason
being that in physics we know that
because we've universally because of the
symmetries of data because of the
symmetries of the world there are
certain sets of universality classes
which means that if you screw up your
microscopic model you will still get a
correct coarse-grained model or at least
could get a correct coarse-grained
models we have no such guarantees in
biology if you start with an incorrect
model of a brain with 10 to the 20
sings interacting with each other and
you start removing this is a bit if you
started with an incorrect model you'll
probably end up with an incorrect
coarse-grained model as well
universality is not going to save you
right and so maybe a better approach is
to do top-down where you start with the
simplest possible model ins and just
refine them add additional features as
needed in order to produce better and
better fits rise and remove features
from a detailed model and there are
multiple different approaches people
have tried the two ones that I like the
most besides what we did is hard lips
ins Eureka engine which I'm sure many of
you have heard about and also recent
work by Brandon on using sparse
regression to fit dynamical systems I'm
not I'm not saying that I'm sorry if I
said this what I'm saying that if you
started with the wrong model you're not
going T there is no reason to expect
that you are going to end up with a with
a good one right you might still but
there is no reason to expect that you
will
so I don't know right III think that
there are some reasons so there it's
effectively what you are what you want
is that as you are coarse graining you
flow towards a better model right the
difference between a correct and
incorrect model becomes smaller and
smaller and smaller and I have I've have
been thinking about this for a couple of
years now but I haven't been able to
come up with a good reason to sort of to
understand under which condition this is
going to be true or not true so so how
do we avoid an exhaustive search through
all possible functions which is
effectively with both Brunton's and Hot
Lips ins approach do right they search
through literally all possible
right-hand side that you can form out of
a certain set of possible elementary
functions put together and you're
allowing up to maybe 20 terms in the
right-hand side and so on this becomes
very very difficult very quickly but on
big machine so how do well boy it says
and the ideas come from really basic
stuff really basic statistics if you're
trying to fit a line right here you
don't really need to know that you know
even if this data comes from science you
can approximate the science with some
polynomials right X x squared X cube and
so on and so forth and you can choose
using standard Bayesian model selection
how many terms do you like to have in
that fit it doesn't matter that your
original model didn't have the right
primitive it didn't have a sign in it
right it only had the power laws but you
still will be able to produce a good fit
and even reasonable extrapolation unless
you are extrapolating too far out right
so maybe we can try to do something
along the same lines the problem is that
when you're trying to fill dynamical
systems when you can start with the
simplest possible sort of linear
dynamical system DX by DT some matrix
times X and then from that point one
there is two ways by which you can make
more senior system more complex right
just you can be adding nonlinearities
just like in our simple example you know
you add xx squared and so on and so
forth terms which each one of this
becomes a larger and larger tensor or
you can add hidden variables right and
it turns out that of course if you are
trying to do model selection in a non
method scenario scenario and now
or of models is infinite then there are
no guarantees that you will not overfeed
if you even do standard Bayesian model
selection so if you want to not to have
such grantees and you have to be doing
search through a nested family of models
and so what we propose is basically you
start with a model the simplest linear
model sits at somewhere here you choose
the most complicated model on the other
end which can fit any dynamics including
any hidden variables and so on and so
forth and then you choose a single pass
or arbitrary parts along this line where
effectively for one non-linearity I add
maybe one hidden variable or for two
non-linearity as I had one hidden
variable or something like that some
weird combination and it doesn't quite
work this way but this is the idea and
you just follow along this path and now
it becomes a nested set of models and
you choose the one that fits the data
best and this is what turns what would
give who determines the right-hand side
for you so this is how it would work in
reality what we do is we start with
models which are almost neural networks
they are not quite right this is a
weighted sum of sigmoid rods and
sigmoids of a weighted sum and for some
reason this is easier for us to to fit
which I don't quite understand why but
of course this is the same as as a
neural network this is basically
dynamical equations on the inputs to a
neuron rather than chemical inputs on
the voltage in in the neuron right and
so the idea is that you have your
original time series DX by DT we are
going to model it with a linear
relaxation input from everything else
plus non dynamical variables that could
exist in data and what you do is for
every time you want to discover a hidden
variable you add one more equation here
and you couple this equation to the all
the previous variable so you start with
maybe if you started with three
variables this would be three nodes and
you added the fourth the fifth the tens
and they all keep coupling to the
previous one right and as I approach it
works quite well and the importance here
is because of all the work that people
have done in neural networks we know
that this type of models can in
principle approximate any dynamics right
if you make them large enough then they
will be able to approximate any dynamics
at least approximately all right
we will repeat there are some I'm
obviously skipping a lot of technical
things we don't quite keep them constant
we try to start from where we were but
we allow them to change us which is a
fitting and so on
another approach yes so what we do is
standard Bayesian model selection right
so we calculate we calculate the
likelihood and then we do not Z naught Z
naught the EIC penalty that's too we
that's not good enough right but we
calculate the dissociation determinants
to the next two orders to non decrease
in orders and the number of data points
which you can do with them CMC something
and so there's a set of models that we
can build as a models which are inspired
by biochemical systems right there's a
generalized mass action kinetics where
production of X is product of functions
of polynomial function functions of X
and the fixed variables the inputs to
the system and then the same for the
degradation and there has been a lot of
work in the late 80s on these systems of
this type and it was proven that this
type of systems can actually not even
approximately but exactly fit any
dynamical system with a right hand side
which is made out from an arbitrary
number of combinations of linear
function of not in your elementary
functions so both of these are complete
sets I can fit any dynamics and by
adding extra equations I have to have
set my pass through the set of all
possible models I'm not going to find
the exact model right I'm going to find
find the model that fits the data
reasonably well and let's see where it
takes us right this is the first example
that we tried which generated a bunch of
about 200 different fake simulated
forever planetary motions around the Sun
planets comets all things like that and
we try to fit and we just gave an equate
with the time series R of T for the our
algorithm and
to feed this data and what the algorithm
immediately told us that it cannot do it
with a single variable it needs to have
two dynamical variables in order to
explain this which of course is a
statement that Newton's laws are second
order differential equations there is R
and there is V and the equation said DV
by DT is equal to force and then it
found the force and the force is because
the actual 1 over R squared is not
within our model within our model
exactly it found an approximation to
that force which we can build using the
in this case as a system approximation
and this is how the phase portrait of
the system look like this is a true
model this is a circle our model didn't
quite fit the circle but pretty much
right this is a pair this is an ellipse
this is an ellipse in our case this is a
hyperbolic parabola in our case the fact
that the scales don't match is not a big
deal for simple reasons that our model
of course doesn't know whether you're
measuring velocity in meters per second
or in kilometers per second doing
whatever else you wanted to measure the
velocity and this is now test on
held-out data where we put a planet with
the initial condition initial whatever
position and velocity and the dotted
lines are what this planet would
actually do and the solid lines is what
our algorithm predicts for this type of
planets yes we don't hear it so we are
working on this in two dimensional
systems you can in two dimensional
systems you can probably try to use some
ideas based off from more Smail
complexes to try to understand whether
this two systems right the true system
and the this one that you that you
observed really the same system in some
sense right so X here is the X's they
are and then so it's R of T so our
differential equations in this case are
dr by dt is equal to something and then
d hidden variable by dt is equal to
something and the feets are given by
these two equations with weird
polynomial right not nonlinear
polynomial right hand sides
if we just give trajectories and in fact
what was what was done here is actually
even simpler what we gave is the initial
point for the planet and then some
random time later what is define what is
the position of that planet not even the
whole trajectory but just two snapshots
at different time points later so let's
try to show me I'll show you a few more
examples okay so here's another example
I'm sorry okay there's another example
from sort of a toy model that people
that everybody uses nowadays and this
field of automatic inference of
dynamical system this is good Kalitta
constellations in East seven species
seven chemical species twenty-eight
parameters complex rational dynamical
laws right it's a nasty system so what
we do the way that we model the system
or what we try to do with the system is
that we say look suppose I only observe
three variables out of seven right and
will on top of that just say that we
have that there is a 10% noise for this
data when of course we explored larger
noises and so on and so forth and so the
data is going to be n samples where as
each individual sample is going to be
three initial conditions for this
chemical species three final conditions
for this chemical species and the
duration of the time between the initial
and final okay so when I say a single
sample it means that seven numbers three
in three final and the time all right
and then we have about and so this is
basic how it's going to look like this
is seven species there is some
oscillatory dynamics that goes on a
neutral condition final condition
initial final and there is total and
samples like this and this is what
happens when we feed this data now this
is an out-of-sample and not just
out-of-sample we're starting with
initial conditions which were not even
within the range of the ones that went
that way straight we're trying to
extrapolate we're always trying to make
predictions right and so the dotted
lines are again what the true system
would be doing and the solid lines is
what our dynamics predicts and the
reason why it's possible
or should be possible to do right well
going back to the same tack and
embedding cerium right if you you don't
need to observe every single variable
right if you observe enough pieces along
the trajectory or observe enough similar
trajectory so you don't even even have
to observe many points along one
trajectory you have a few similar
initial conditions and then you look at
few outputs at different time points
from the similar initial conditions you
in principle may be able to do this fits
there is no serious about that but I'm
not a mathematician I've sort of
practical physicists in some sense right
and so instead it works right in this
case what is even more interesting if
you notice the original system has seven
variables our in third system has six
and this gave me a big bit of sort of a
worry the first time we looked at this
but then we realized that there is a
conservation law in the original system
carbon is conserved right carbon just
goes through all of these reactions and
and in fact there's only six independent
variables and here is a system has
managed to figure out that six variables
is enough the three hidden variables
have nothing to do or there's some beard
combinations of the four other hidden
variables and I don't know what they are
and I really don't care the point that
we're making good predictions okay so
now let me take you to real data
application and I want to talk about two
we'll talk about one because I'm running
so late so what we wanted to do to model
is something where the microscopical
model just doesn't exist and won't exist
because the system is so complex can we
try to figure out what what the system
is doing and so here we have the C
elegans this is data from will rules lab
and every time the green dot in a green
dot a striking is ahead of C elegans and
every time door turns red it means that
were hitting it with an extra infrared
laser it's hot it doesn't like it as it
doesn't like the temperature increase
very very much and so it requires back
and so what we try to do is we try to
understand can i model dynamical system
of this warm where the input is the
temperature that's experiencing and the
output is its velocity okay can I build
a model and can I make some predictions
that I didn't put in the specific
question that is interested people in
this field is whether the two behaviors
where the warm is going forward and
going backwards are two independent at
actors in the system right it's a
forward attractor and the reverse
attractor and then by heating a laser by
giving a laser you are biasing the
relative strengths of the two attractors
right so the formal attractor is more is
it is more stable when there is no laser
light and the backwards attractor is
stable more stable when there is laser
light versus another possibility where
there is just one attractor can
continuously borrow in behavior where by
increasing temperature the warmth
preference doesn't switch from forward
to backwards but sort of goes
continuously from going forward with
some velocity to going backwards it with
some with some velocity right and that's
been a question for a couple of years in
this C elegans field not sure how
important this is overall but I think
that I mean for C elegans but I think
that the question of whether the
behaviors get formed by stimuli whether
the behaviors exist there and we just
switch between some behaviors right is
probably an important question even for
larger animals like us and so this is a
snapshot of the data this would be the
laser profiles that the worm experiences
there were different three different
heat intensities I'm only showing three
in reality that we tried continuous
numbers between whatever small and large
this would be the responses to this
profiles average between a bunch of
different worms and these are now five
different values for worms this is what
our model does right this is the best
feed that we produce and so the fits are
reasonably good right
it's a velocity that we predict are
there they're reasonably good you can
even try to make sense of this model the
idea is that first of all you need a
second variable the worm is not
completely controlled by Z by Z by Z
temperature it has some memory right
which by itself is an interesting
statement this memory is suppressed by
as a laser current and then there is a
self there is negative feedback velocity
sort of on velocity so the system wants
to relax the velocity to a certain
particular value which is determined by
the memory and the laser intensity so
you can make a story right why this is
reasonable and very similar wiring
diagrams have existed in systems where
people looked at sort of point stimuli
and the responses to this point stimuli
like for example equaliser might came up
access or a collector metaxas very
similar wiring diagrams are actually
molecularly
present in those systems but I don't
want to really look at this equations I
mean they are not meaningful can i why
should we trust them right what's how do
I know that they are correct or not so
and do they answer the question that I
asked originally so this is the phase
portrait of the system this is the speed
of the warm this is a recoil negative
speed going forward is positive speed
and this is a hidden variables in memory
and when you hit the laser current what
happened he hit the laser what happens
is that I keep on having a single
attractor at least in our model a single
attractor that immediately moves once
once the temperature raises moves to the
negative velocity and then the warm
tries to chase this attractor right so
and the attractor keeps on moving itself
why because the as the warm is moving
the temperature that the warm is
experienced and is changing as well and
so in this sort of chase of attractor
moving around and the warm moving around
trying to change that factor you get
this typical negative recoil velocity
this is at least what we predict why
should we trust this right why if I tell
you that the behaviors continuously
controlled why should you trust this and
I think the test as always since this
what I started with tests and all of
this models is whether you can make
predictions about things that you didn't
put in okay and so here we train the
data on the first one and a half seconds
or so off recoil where as warm is just
going back and the our model doesn't
even know that our data doesn't even
know that some time later in about two
seconds or so or two and a half seconds
the warm is going to stop and start
going forward again the velocity is
going to hit zero and go and so let's
try to predict from our model at which
point the velocity is going to become
zero and the warm is going to turn and
now we start going forward again after
the recoil and again that has never been
put into the model in training and I can
predict this time to change to the four
best motion as a function of laser
intensity and so the this is the average
behaviour the dotted lines are the dots
are the average behaviors from the
experiment and this is our prediction or
I can try to predict the time of change
to the forward velocity as a function of
the maximum speed that the
warm experiences and so here the
predictions are I would say perfect
right this is just there's no error bars
here because there is just one or two
points here so we don't really know and
so the predictions are so good that it
means that we are at least capturing
some truths about the internal dynamics
or at least some some properties of the
dynamics so it we can make these
predictions about things that are way
out into the future and which we haven't
read right so the model knows something
what you also see is how variable
different warms are every dot is a warm
right and so the part which I'm going to
skip is how do we take this ideas for
thematic inference and do the following
thing to model individuality by in
imposing that every single individual in
your data set has to have the same
phenomenological model the same
physiological model yet the parameters
of the models could be different right
so you are learning a model for
everybody at the same time and then
fitting the individual parameters of the
model on each individual worm or in that
case we also did it for pancreatic
beta-cells because that's where a lot
more money is and in the worms and and
that's a part which I'm skipping for now
right and so with that I want to
summarize that yeah I think that one
when one is building the models of of
biological systems and trying to
understand them that maybe they
emphasizing the truth of a model and
instead focusing on how good is the
model at predicting is at least maybe
not the way of going forward but it's an
alternative way to going forward which I
personally subscribe to and others may
or may not right if you are doing this
and maybe it's a better thing to refine
model threads and coarse-grain models
because for the same argument that we
just had with Peter it might be that
coarse graining models which are
improperly specified is not going to
give you a correct and monological model
and maybe you should start with building
models from top down and add features
only as necessary right and technically
what we are doing is we're building
complete and completed a complete and
nested model families of dynamical
systems we can essentially enumerate all
possible dynamical systems or can come
very close to an output of any dynamical
systems with these two sets of models
and such models actually make reasonable
accurate predictions right and so here
is the end of my final sentence what I
would like to sort of to make a
distinction of why doing this and what's
the difference between a model and a
theory right and so in my mind the
difference is following if I go back to
17th century to Robert Hooke who is
measuring force versus just the
extension curves in a spring right and
so he takes a single curve a single
spring and he plots the extension versus
a force and he gets a linear relation
and that's an interesting observation
right it's a model that this particular
spring which is made of this particular
metal etc et-cetera is given by this
particular model with the coefficient
whose constant that is whatever it is
right and then you can keep on doing it
on other Springs and every single time
you hit it that it's a linear dependence
but K is different linear dependence but
K is different right and at that point
you realize that maybe there is more to
it than just that this particular spring
spring is a linear spring all Springs
are right and so at that point it
becomes not just a model but a theory of
the small displacements or small
extensions of all possible Springs that
you are going to look at and that's
basically our goal right so what what
I'm trying to do is trying to build
models of similar classes of phenomena
in this case warm escape and we're
looking at escape to different stimuli
and we're also looking at at the same
temperature escape responses in in
different organisms and so on and so
trying to build phenomena of models of
similar classes of phenomena and then
trying to stare at them and try to see
what is similar between all of this
model that we have built and trying to
see you know aha maybe all of the
temperature responses in all of the
animals of the size are given by this
fit forward triangle that I put on the
previous slide or maybe not and we'll
see in a few years
[Applause]
just play something I'm sorry I miss how
you actually determine the hidden viable
and wait so again it didn't miss I
didn't tell that's right so so so we
start with a different system of if I
have two dimensional or one demand let's
say one dimensional time series I start
with a one dimensional dynamical system
and I try to feed the dynamical system
within the class of possible ones that I
that I'm allowed to if it doesn't work
or rather and then I try to add another
variable and try to now feel a two
dimensional dynamical system just
integrate it and try to see as an out
that the first variable is required to
feed the data and second one is allowed
to do whatever the dynamics tells it to
be and I can try to do it with three
dimensional four dimensional and I can
do it because we're not fitting every or
not trying every dynamics but we're
trying dynamics only within a certain
class of dynamics that is true I
wouldn't say that the trajectories are
very reached so in this case what we
what we started is in all of these
examples we just have two points along
the trajectory we have multiple
different initial conditions right so
it's not a single trajectory but but
there are multiple trajectories very
sparsely sampled right there is some
trade-off if you have if you want to
mature the dynamics and the individual
parameters for each specific warm which
specific cell whatever it is then you
will probe then you will definitely want
to have individual trajectories to be
longer and then many cells together are
many worms together give their own
trajectories but but if you want to just
infer one models and you don't even have
which don't need to have which
trajectories you can just have one input
one outlet and many of those
this is what works and I agree with this
I'm not going to disagree right and I
think that this is the same story that
if you're trying to predict reasonably
reasonably similar dynamics nothing
really in really crazy is going on then
it looks like we got it right if there
was something really crazy going on you
know looking far out you know whereas a
warm at that point is now starting to
make loops etc like ten seconds out
right we wouldn't be able to predict it
but again looking back at Newton's you
know gravity the fact that it cannot
predict what would that there exist
black holes doesn't make it a bad theory
right every theory is designed for a
certain class of conditions right to
some extent I think yes I mean the
Occam's razor Tom let you in this case
extrapolation I'm not arguing it so I
don't think that for example our
approach would be very good at figuring
out what's going on in detail because we
not in microscopic a microscopic mapping
or whatever dynamics to the microscopic
variables because we are at the outset
not interested in that right we didn't
design the system to do this and so if
that's what you're asking for if you are
trying to figure out which chemical do
you need to add in order to block a
certain synapse and probably that
synapse and that chemical have to be in
your model and and the model cannot just
glance over it right but if that's not
what you're asking then then what we do
but that being said sorry one one second
right but that being said what we have
tried to do is the following we can
start with a lot of sort of microscopic
models and this way I do in most in
systems biology context because there
there are just fewer parameters to play
with so we're starting with various
small microscopically accurate models
and then trying to figure out what these
models would be inferred as when you do
phenomenological inference and I'm sort
of trying to build a dictionary between
which kind of microscopic phenomena
models are going to be mapped into the
same phenomenological model right it's
not one-to-one dictionary it's
many-to-one by by construction but
that's what we're trying to do at least
to guide an answer to this question
rather than maybe fully give the answer
to this question
and we're trying to do this it turns out
again in two dimensions you can classify
every dynamical system right it's not
hard right but once you start moving and
so you can answer this question what it
is that my system is doing because you
know that there is only a certain set of
two-dimensional systems right but in
higher number of dimensions this is a
question for every dynamical system
people don't know right you can you
start with a three dimensional dynamical
system you reprobate rise the variables
and you will get a different set of
equations we don't have tools to
establish similarity that this well this
is exactly the same systems right we
cannot even say that they're exactly the
same sort of searching for through all
possible repair motorisation of three
variables to three other variables right
and so what we are trying to do is
basically do very similar thing with
that I mentioned a minute ago about
building dictionaries more or less right
so we're trying to figure out what what
would happen to a certain class of large
dimensional system how they would be
inferred in in our case if used and
build basically similarity metrics
between different dynamical systems
based on whether the same closed
trajectories are mapped into the same
closed points at the end of the
trajectory and and and sort of try to
see how the cones of equivalent sort of
expand and so on and so forth and and
build the dictionaries of that this
seven dimensional system and this seven
dimensional system means that right and
this one's milled means that but again
it yeah we should stop them yes I'm
sorry
[Applause]